logan is directed by james mangold and
is the final portrayal of wolverine by
hugh jackman or so he says james mangold
last directed the wolverine which i
thought was pretty good up until the
third act which got really silly but up
until then I was like yes this is what I
need and if you watch the extended cut
of the Wolverine it's even better so I
was happy that James Mangold was
returning to direct this final portrayal
of such an iconic character I'm going to
go very light on the plot synopsis
because I got to see this very early at
a press screening and basically Logan
has to cart this girl around he's not
entirely sure what her backstory is and
as he learns more about it he learns
more about himself as well so as
Wolverine is slicing and dicing various
bad guys
he and Professor X have to try to
protect this girl who may not really
need that much protection because she's
got some tricks up her sleeve this is
also the first movie featuring Wolverine
to be rated R this film is brutal oh my
god there is so much blood and limbs I
loved it they really didn't hold
anything back Wolverine goes absolutely
berserk on people in this movie he's
chopping off limbs
he's impaling people and it's not
squeaky clean there's blood everywhere
and my god
it's fucking great from an action
standpoint this is probably my favorite
in the x-men universe not just because
of the fact that it doesn't hold back
but because Wolverine is old he's tired
he's broken down he's beaten physically
and emotionally he's doing back-alley
drug deals to get pills for Professor X
I mean this guy is just a complete
shadow of what he used to be so when
someone comes around challenging him
it's amazing to see that old Wolverine
come out that insane Weapon X that we've
come to love in other movies really come
to fruition again when just the right
buttons are pushed and this is something
that I expected going in knowing that
it's rated R knowing that rating says
strong brutal bloody violence that's
what I want to see and we do get that
but from an emotional standpoint I was
very satisfied with Logan in regards to
the fact this is more in line with what
Christopher Nolan did with Batman
less of what we've seen with the
Avengers Marvel movies this is a very
somber serious drama that contains
exciting bursts of action throughout
this isn't a movie where our heroes walk
around sad and depressed the entire time
it's not completely devoid of humor it
has a lot of fun in there as well and
some good jokes but it is kept at a very
gracious minimum this is a dark violent
movie in which very little hope remains
for these characters they're at about
99.9% done with hope there is a very
tiny little shred of it remaining in
these characters eyes it is so great and
riveting to see these characters we've
grown to love put in a place that's so
dark and so small and almost completely
forgotten about that you just want to
see them climb out of the hole they're
in and watching these characters
especially the young girl in the film
grow to appreciate one another and learn
to help each other again and be heroes
again it was fantastic this movie makes
the curious choice of having the x-men
comics physically exist in this world
and they're viewed as these fictional
stories that people wrote based off of
the real heroes so Wolverine picks up an
x-men comic and looks through a Yaz's
bullsháá and throws it away you know
that's actually really smart I love that
because it takes place in the future of
the timeline established in Days of
Future past so you can do a lot with
what took place in between those two
films and apparently a lot of people are
very happy with the x-men and view them
as heroes and so there's comic books
that exist in this world about them and
it's really actually a very smart and
fresh idea and I like the fact that
include that in there I would say the
first act and the third act of this
movie are the best those two acts are
extremely riveting very fast paced
intense they almost feel like westerns
there's a definite Western sense to this
movie that James Mangold is going for
even right down to a scene where the
characters are watching the movie Shane
on TV but the second act turns into a
roadtrip movie of sorts and it meanders
a little bit nothing from a dramatic
standpoint that's very interesting is
happening there also wasn't a lot of
action for that period that act was
really taken to make the little girl and
Wolverine grow as
characters and it wasn't quite as
interesting as I think it could have
been the film sometimes chooses to focus
on characters that are nowhere near as
compelling as the ones that we want it
to focus on it sometimes takes way too
much time with other characters that I
feel don't really have that much weight
or impact to this movie the film also
makes another interesting choice for the
characters that to my knowledge has no
basis in the comics I believe the
writers have completely invented this
character for some it might be a
distraction gratefully it's handled
pretty well it's actually kind of scary
what they do with a specific character
in this film that to my knowledge as I
said is completely invented by the
screenwriters his addition in this movie
is fairly miniscule but some are
probably going to be annoyed by it
because it's sort of invented again I've
read a lot of x-men comics but I haven't
read all of them so if I'm wrong I'm
wrong but I think he mostly worked for
this movie and I think that if fans can
accept the fact that not everything in
these movies has to be perfectly like
the comics and that these are
adaptations of the comics and I think
most men will be ok with it especially
since it's brutal and kind of terrifying
actually now of course no spoilers but
as for the way everything wraps up in
this movie I found it to be pretty
satisfying I did want just a little bit
more emotionally just maybe a couple
more little punches to my gut but for
the most part everything ended in a way
that I think is very satisfactory for
longtime fans and for myself in
particular it's not a perfect movie
sometimes the tone and the pacing of it
all gets a little jumbled but as a final
portrayal of this character Hugh Jackman
was just so fuckin badass he knocked it
out of the park once again for one last
time seeing our beloved will be so
broken and learning about his past some
things he maybe didn't even want to know
about it was kind of heart-wrenching and
he did a fantastic job Patrick Stewart
is also amazing in this movie I love the
little girl as well I thought she was
very good James Mangold's vision for
this movie is very beautiful I think
it's a very good-looking movie very well
edited I liked Logan quite a bit I'm
going to give it an A - guys if you
can't tell right now I am sick as hell I
have had the worst cold
add in years and I drove myself to the
theater tonight I have not yet seen the
Great Wall or a cure for wellness or
anything this weekend I just was like go
see Logan you have to see it you got to
get this video up I'll try to get the
Great Wall up as soon as I can
sorry I just might throw up my so I've
had like this flu I was having weird
like fever dreams the other night it was
crazy anyway guys thank you very much
for watching and if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Applause]
[Music]